NAT allows multiple networks to reuse the
same private IP address space. Let's suppose that
we have two networks. These networks might
be, for example, homes or they might be
larger networks in regions of the Internet,
where IPv4 address space is scarce, for example,
in developing regions. What NAT allows these networks
to do is reuse the same portion of
internet address space. For example, a particular, special, private IP address
space, is 192.168/16. Other private IP address space
is specified in RFC 3130. Now, obviously these two networks couldn't
coexist on the public Internet, because routers
wouldn't know if they got a packet destined
for an IP address in this space, which network the packet should be sent to.
What a NAT, or a Network Address
Translator does, is take the private IP addresses
that are behind the NAT and translate those
IP addresses to a single, globally visible IP
address. Now, to the rest of the Internet, network one appears to be reachable
by a single IP address, 203.178.1.1, and network two is reachable
via a single distinct global IP
address 133.4.1.5. Now, a host back here, say
192.168.1.10 might send a packet towards a global
internet destination. Now, the key behind NAT is
that this packet has a source port and
the NAT is basically going to take that
source IP address and port and it's going to
translate it into a publicly reachable source IP
address and port, and the destination will remain
the same. That packet will make its way
to a global destination and the reply will make
its way to the globally reachable IP address on
the corresponding port. Now, when that packet with that
particular destination IP address and port reaches the NAT,
the NAT has a table that knows the mapping
between that public IP address and port and the
private one that it rewrote to generate the corresponding
public IP address and port. So we can
simply now rewrite the destination IP address of this
packet to the corresponding private address and port. NATs
are popular on broadband access networks, small or home
offices and VPNs. There's a clear savings in
IPv4 address space, since there can be many many
devices in one of these private networks and yet
all of the devices that are behind the NAT
only use up one public IP Address. The drawback,
of course, is that the end to end model is
broken. And we talked about the end to end
model in a previous lesson and let me just remind
you how NAT breaks it. If the NAT device
failed in this instance, for example, the mapping between the
private source IP address and port and the public source
IP address and port would be lost. Thereby breaking all
active connections for which the NAT is on
the path. It's also asymmetric. Under ordinary circumstances
it's rather difficult for a host on the global Internet to reach a device in a
private address space in network one or network
two, because by default those devices in these
private networks do not have public globally reachable
IP addresses. So, NAT both breaks end-to-end communication and
it also breaks by directional communication.